تصريحات التي نقلناها لمحامي ترامب تقول
بانهم طلبوا واتفقوا على اي لا يتم تقييد
ترامب رغم انه في تصريحات سابقه كانت تشير
انه ترامب من مصلحته ان تتم عمليه تقييده
حتى ياخذ تعاطف اكثر ويحصل على تعاطف اكثر
من قبل المتابعين
بالفعل الميسون واخيرا حسم الامر بهذه
القضيه لانه كان هناك جدل كبير حولها ان
كان سيتم تقييده او انه سيتم معاملته
معامله خاصه بكونه كان رئيسا سابقا
للولايات المتحده وهذاك مكان اشار اليه
حتى محاميه السابق وخصمه الان مايكل كوهن
الذي قال انه يتمنى الا يتم تقيده كما يتم
التقييد المجرمين
يتوجه لهم التهم وهم اشخاص عاديون
بطبيعه الحال ترامب كما تفضلتي كان يتمنى
كما نقل عنه بان يتم تقييده لانه
سيلقى تعاطفا من قبل قاعدته الجمهوريه
المتعاطفه معه اصلا زخما اكبر في هذه
القضيه ولكن الان الامر حسم كما اصبح ايضا
معروفا بانه ستؤخذ صوره ستجمع او ستاخذ
ايضا ايضا بصماته وفي تفاصيل عن حيثيات
هذه القضيه لانه لائحه الاتهام بحسب ما
افهم حتى الان غير معروفه او في معلومات
كثيره حول هذه النقطه
بالفعل ميسون لا احد الاتهام لا احد
يستطيع ان يتحدث عنها الان الا الفراق
المدعي العام لمنهات ولكن بحسب ما علمنا
من صحف امريكيه نقلا عن مصادر من هيئه
المحلفين بيانات تتضمن جنائيه واحده هنا
لابد من الاشاره والتوضيح بان ترامب
التهمه التي توجه اليه لتزوير بيانات وهي
جنايه او هي جنحه عفوا وليست
جنايه اذا اثبت انه دفع اموالا تنتهك
قوانين الحمله الانتخابيه تمويل الحمله
الانتخابيه عند اذن تكون جنايه تزوير
البيانات تعتبر جنحه ولا ترقى الى جنايه
اما دفع اموال تنتهك قوانين تمويل الحمله
الانتخابيه هي جنايه ولهذا السبب يرى
الكثير من الخبراء القانونيين في الحقيقه
هنا ان هذه القضيه قضيه من هاته هي الاضعف
بين القضايا الاخرى لان اتهاماتها
اتهاماتها لا تشكل خطرا كبيرا على دونالد
ترامب اذا مقورنت بالتحقيق المتعلق بدوره
في اقتحام الكونغرس وايضا الدوره في
الاتصال الذي اجراه ليقلب النتائج في
جورجيا كما
ايضا اضافه طبعا الى كيفيه تعامله